now this is eight news now live at six
live local now
well you can hear it there just chaos on
the busy i-15 as nevada highway patrol
chases a man with you as you heard there
the trooper still stuck
inside his car now trooper micah
may is fighting for his life over at umc
good evening to you thank you for
joining us on 8 news now at 6 i'm brian
loftis
and i'm denise valdez may was struck
while attempting to put out one of those
spike strips during their pursuit on the
freeway
joe moeller is live he's outside of umc
with more
on how the trooper is doing now joe
o'brien more than 24 hours after this
incident happened troopers are still out
here for
trooper may now the latest update from
nhp is that
he is listed in critical condition here
at umc i'll take a live look here at the
hospital we learned
he is married with two kids and his
family is also here with him the nevada
highway patrol shared a photo with us
earlier today
may is 46 years old and has been with
the department of public safety since
2008.
earlier today we watched as more family
arrived here at the hospital
the injured police officer fund is
collecting donations for expenses for
may
and his family i spoke to sergeant
chelsea stunkel the president of that
fund
who says they are doing what they can
during this difficult time
he's gravely injured in the hospital and
family had to fly in to be with him
the wife and kids are there and anyone
who's been in the hospital knows you're
there around the clock you don't want to
leave your loved one's side so
we're going to help with airfare hotels
food
child care if need be
the investigation into yesterday's
pursuit of the carjacking suspect
continues we learned metro officers who
were assisting
were not the ones who opened fire on
that now dead suspect
metro as the department investigating
this incident and
there are ways you can donate in that
fund we do have uh the
link to do so up on our website that is
eight newsnow dot com
nhp says they will be giving more
updates soon as soon as we learn more
information we'll be sure to pass it
along reporting live outside of umc joe
moller 8 news now